you guys are probably getting annoyed by
us mentioning Dark Souls every time code
vein comes up but we just got our first
glimpse of the gameplay and it actually
does look pretty dark in Soul Z I'm Tony
and this is your blood-drenched game
spot news update code vein is about
vampires in a post-apocalyptic world who
hunt down big monsters to take their
blood and boost their powers we already
knew the premise but the first trailer
shows off these post-apocalyptic
environments with crumbling cities and
icy caves and dark tunnels more
importantly we got our first look at
combat and there's plenty of rolling to
the left and attacking big nasty looking
monsters we also get a brief glimpse at
the game's companion mechanic a sidekick
whose own powers can bolster your combat
strategy I'm expecting plenty more
trailers and info in the coming months
so make sure you're subscribed to be the
first to see all the new stuff code vein
is developed by the team behind God
Eater and published by the same company
that handled Dark Souls and that's all
pretty evident in the trailer it doesn't
really clear up the release window
though so for now all we know is that
code vein is coming to some assortment
of home consoles in 2018 but for a
different breed of Tokyo violence right
now you can check out 10 things we wish
we knew before starting persona 5
[Music]